estamos hablando sobre cuál fue el punto
de quiebre para que esta semana el
presidente de gotabaya rajapaksa huyera
del país y afirmara que va a renunciar
es el fin de la era de los raya pasadita
dictando los destinos decir blanca
si es un momento muy relevante sobre
todo porque su hermano azil tener al
ministro de finanzas ya desde el mes de
marzo había renunciado eso quiere decir
que se establece en una dinámica
realmente importante
en cuanto a la imposibilidad que ellos
sigan en el poder es bien interesante
también porque ya los partidos políticos
del parlamento entre ellos poder
político con otros líderes supremamente
relevantes como es el caso específico de
que cuando tenemos con el nombre del
plan de madhu abandera han establecido
ya que van a hacer un gobierno interino
y que el premier quien está en el
momento en el poder debe abandonarlo
totalmente para poder seguir con una
transición en momentos tan complejos
como sabemos con una crisis que se
establece prácticamente en forma
alimentaria bueno y el pueblo parece
decidido a lograr cambios pero ante esta
ola de protestas y los aliados de los
rayados ya aún en el poder hay riesgos
de una espiral de violencia
totalmente sobre todo porque nos
encontramos ante una tormenta perfecta
donde no tienen gasolina no tienen
materias primas no tienen alimentos y
como lo hemos visto en otras
revoluciones a lo largo de la historia y
en las más cercanas cuando la gente está
con un nivel de descontrol tan fuerte
pues y donde vemos unas violaciones
masivas de los derechos humanos en este
contexto lo que encontramos es la
gasolina totalmente puesta sobre la mesa
para entrar entrar en un momento
anárquico que es lo que no se quiere dar
eso es fundamentalmente lo que
encontramos y que necesita hacer y la
ncaa para salir de la crisis económica y
política en la que se encuentra
es muy complejo porque es un tema
estructural que lo vemos ya de varias
décadas tuvo una guerra civil entre 1983
y 2009 pero de igual manera también es
la mano amiga de unos gobiernos muy
cercanos entre los cuales ya se ve india
el fondo monetario internacional sobre
una renegociación pero sobre todo
hablamos de una deuda superior a los 51
mil millones de dólares por ende serán
meses supremamente complejos y más que
meses años donde tendrán que aumentar
todos los temas de impuestos y esto no
va a gustar nada a la población